hello everyone i'm judge jeanine pirro
along with jessica tarlog pete hexset
martha mccallum and greg gutfeld it's
five o'clock in new york city and this
is the five
[Music]
he promised to unite america but now joe
biden is smearing half the country as
extremist with his poll numbers and free
fall and his party headed for a white
house for a wipeout in the midterms
biden thinks it's politically prudent to
borrow a page out of hillary clinton's
playbook
let me tell you about this ultra mega
agenda it's extreme as most mega things
are ultra mag agenda i don't want to
hear republicans talk about deficits and
their ultra mega agenda the republicans
the mega republicans the mag of
republicans you don't want to
mispronounce it the mega republicans
this mega crowd is really the most
extreme political organization that's
existed in american history
but mr unity seems to forget that it's
his party that's full of extremists
far-left democrats like the squad want
to defund police departments everywhere
they want to open the border wide open
to criminal cartels by letting title 42
expire and they want to push their
divisive woke ideology into every facet
of life
biden igniting a backlash with his
comments he's essentially saying that
this quote-unquote maga crowd
are worse than terrorists no matter how
you feel about the maga crowd this is an
authoritarian assault on our freedom i
thought joe biden wanted to stand for
unity he's never stood for that he's
been one of the most divisive presidents
we've ever had
okay martha i watched your show today
you had a lot on this and it just seems
that this is joe biden's deplorable
moment a guy who's so low in terms of
the poll numbers right now facing the
midterms in uh in just under six months
why would he be calling everybody else
deplorable yeah it didn't work very well
for hillary clinton right and and you
can imagine that um president trump and
supporters and trump candidates look at
this and they go thank you
this is exactly what we needed thank you
very much because you've just alienated
half the country but what i find so
fascinating is just how much he has
pulled against his own
former thinking right
and he could be taking this moment and
saying you know i understand how you
feel um people who support what the
justices apparently are going to decide
because i once felt that way myself in
fact as a senator he said about roe v
wade i don't like the supreme court
decision on abortion i think it went too
far
then he said when he was
a proponent with republicans under the
reagan administration of doing exactly
what's happening right now of scratching
roe v wade and sending it back to the
states he advocated for that he wanted
to vote for that amendment uh and he
said it was because he's a roman
catholic he said i'm probably a victim
or a product however you want to phrase
it on my background so he he's
alienating everyone who and you know
what the truth is that most people are
somewhat
more in the middle on this issue right i
mean our own fox news poll
54
of the people who answered it think that
15 weeks
is where the ban should be okay 15 weeks
is what the mississippi law was about
right it lines up with what you see in
most of europe this is not a radical
opinion when you look at how people
stand on this so um i think this is an
unwise position for him politically and
i think that he's going to sort of feed
right into the hands of what uh his
opposition is gonna where they want him
to be you know jessica one of the things
that biden said that really stunned me
was he said quote i am not prepared to
leave issues of privacy to the whims of
the public if he's so convinced that
this is an issue where the public is
with him and the court is so wrong why
is he willing to let the states decide
let congress pass a law
well congress will pass a law or they're
going to try to next week um and i i saw
something that i thought was really
smart because there are 13 states right
now that if
if the alito draft comes to fruition
will immediately
make abortion illegal or it'll go to six
weeks and that's preferably making it
illegal um
pass something a little more moderate to
get it done and that might have some
prayer of passing the senate so in the
house have a conversation about a
15-week ban when you're staring at 13
and i think it's 20 states that have
these trigger laws
um
get something done that then you have to
put moderate republicans on the back
foot in the senate to have to come
forward and explain why they won't take
this middle ground approach you're not
saying abortion is legal up until nine
months you're saying 15 weeks same as
most of europe what the mississippi law
is and make them make a decision so
that's where i i think they'd be smart
to go but they will pass something in
congress and then it'll fail in the
senate and then we'll be back to square
one on this and it will continue to be
ugly i think what we saw from joe biden
and i don't think that his comment was
anywhere near
having the impact that the deplorables
comment was because talking about maga
republicans is separate than talking
about republicans as a whole he's
talking about people that are big trump
supporters and people who have been
calling liberals you know libtards and
people with tds and crooked hillary
clinton he's got 90 support inside the
republican party half the country
well it's it's 60 million people or 70
million people who voted for him but it
isn't really half the country first of
all people more people should
participate but there are a lot of
people who vote for a person who is on
the ballot because they support the
policies of the party when they don't
really like the person a lot of people
had their own
vote for trump's name they didn't use
his name they just said mega but that
was his motto his slogan was make
america great again which is what magga
comes from and you wear hats that say
magga yeah you wear shirts that yeah
yeah but it's not derogatory it's
intense
like the deplorable statement because
he's saying you know all these people
and then it offends a lot of people i'm
not saying as a pr person i would not
have said go out today and say that
there's a lot of somebody did because he
said it about 14 times it was not a
mistake all right then let me go let me
go to pete you know one of the things
that the white house did not seem
concerned about at all today and
gensakes seemed not to have any response
was the doxing uh and the information on
the supreme court justices the five who
are
joined in this opinion so that people
can protest in front of their homes i
mean that is typical of what the left
does the right doesn't do this those are
the people that's why they call it the
lawless left why can't the white house
condemn that
they haven't even come out and said the
leak is worth condemning
let alone the doxing of supreme court
members so we're going to try to
intimidate them at their homes because
they i mean they're so far down the
train that they say that speech itself
is violence and therefore in response to
that speech violence is justified or
doxing the home addresses of people uh
because in politics is religion for them
and as a result they're going to go the
ends always justify the means and i
think in this particular case
they're ramping up the fear because they
don't have any alternatives so peg the
fear meter to max on roe v wade even
though everyone knows this is going back
to the states the congress the senate's
not going to but that does mean an
abortion ban in a lot of states and
that's what people vote for they live in
those states they don't believe they're
yelling but no one else is yelling okay
oh people thank you that's what people
vote for they vote for representatives
who pass laws on their behalf the closer
to the people that government happens
the better off that's what democracy
which the left talks about is always for
and then they're ramping up the fear on
the mega crowd demonize the opponent and
make the opponent the bad guy
mischaracterize a straw man and hope you
can win against that and i don't think
they can well you know greg so it comes
to you i mean there is there are a
couple of issues right now the president
and the left is now trying to convince
everyone this is the end of gay marriage
interracial marriage contraceptive
loving versus virginia griswold versus
connecticut all of these states when the
opinion in three separate places says
this decision has nothing to do with
those other cases and i could read it if
anyone's interested they can email me
i mean they're counting on the fact that
no one is going to read it and the fact
is no one really does except for people
like you read it i didn't read it i
trust you though when you talk about it
so i know that you're telling me the
truth but most people they're they're on
their phones doing other stuff they're
not going to read it so when they hear
this stuff from joe biden which made no
sense he combined like three different
issues when he was talking about this it
was he's such a it's it's actually not
you don't get mad about it you kind of
get sad because he's an empty vessel
which is why he repeated that slogan it
was like the software was put in yeah
right they put the maga software in and
it just sputtered and came to life and
he got stuck maga
maga anyway but this is the latest
example of a commoner smear you know
whatever you think about trump right
being mean prone to ridicule or whatever
he always punched up he went after the
media he went after politicians
celebrities and even athletes he never
really i don't think he ever singled out
a democratic voter or democratic voters
because he wanted them that's part of
the salesman's the salesman wants to get
everybody but the democrats are punch
the democrat leaders not democrats but
the democrat leaders punch down they do
it in two ways they smear millions of
people under one thing whether it's mag
or deplorables or they chase an
individual down in the media whether it
is for posting a meme or wearing a maga
hat why are you doing this why did you
say that that sort of thing but this is
part of a larger trend which is um
because the modern woke
frames everything as moral or immoral
when you were talking about like
religion politics as a religion it's
actually a flip from the republicans of
the 80s the moral majority is now on the
left and so there's no room for
forgiveness
and that's why canceled culture was able
to explode without any breaks you
couldn't do nobody could punch the
brakes because the brakes are
forgiveness so what you're seeing is
this incredible flip which is the
democrats now are less forgiving and
more judgmental and the republicans are
the open tent and you're seeing all of
these new and unusual republicans
caitlyn jenner you're getting you're
getting uh people that were normally
ex-liberals and this is an overarching
theme if you look at the masked against
the unmask the denigration of parents at
the altar of woke sex ed the let them
eat cake narratives about food shortages
and gas prices there's a disdain for the
unwashed masses
and it's it's what we always thought the
country club republicans were that was
the stereotype but secretly it's always
been the modern regressive left who
hates the masses and i think this is
part of it yeah interesting hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else